san Francisco's late 60s music scene was
defined by acts like the Grateful Dead
Janis Joplin and Jefferson Airplane
while their music remains popular to
this day one band of four groundbreaking
women from that era is getting a second
chance fifty years later John Blackstone
has their story
San Francisco's haight-ashbury
intersection made famous during the
summer of love he is more than just a
memory for the four women posing under
the iconic street signs in 1965 at an
apartment around the corner they started
playing music together as the Ace of
Cups an all-girl rock band Denis Kaufman
Mary Gannon lead guitarist Mary Ellen
Simpson and drummer Diane Whittle it's
50 years ago they were right at the
center of San Francisco's exploding
music scene you started to get some
pretty prominent gigs Fillmore yeah and
seen Janice being being backstage so
backstage with janis joplin sharing the
stage with what other groups Jefferson
Airplane the band the band Santana and
Jimi Hendrix so there you were on the
same stage with Jefferson Airplane and
Jimi Hendrix what happened well first of
all we didn't get a record deal at that
time and that was sort of the next step
for us and it was the same step that our
brother bands were taking and if you
didn't record you never got a fan base
farther away than your local situation
and so then you didn't really get to
tour so all of those things that would
have been part of the next step never
really happened for us
half a century later they finally have a
record deal they're back together all
well into their 70s but it seems like
the 60s all over again when they start
to play their performance raises the
mystery of why they were never offered a
record deal so long ago did that next
step not come because you're a girl band
maybe one of the aspects of it I would
say that and then we started having
children and we really couldn't afford
to you know go on the road and just got
harder songs they'd written and
performed like on the road gathered dust
as they each went on to other lives well
I had all the usual suspect jobs of
waitressing I became a substance abuse
counselor and I ended up taking my
personal practice which was yoga and
that became a profession or livelihood
to me for some years became a house
cleaner
mostly gardening you know I have bees I
moved to LA to go to music school I went
back to school in my 50s and got my
diploma for special ed and started
playing in top 40 bands became an
emergency medical technician
[Music]
I've got my compass in my dream I mean
have you had the dream that you have
today have you had that please all these
years well I think we always wanted to
share the music I know for me I felt
like I didn't ever think that would
really happen that the music that we had
written together would actually find its
way to the world my thought it was you
know that we would kind of treasure it
you know but it'd be like having little
children that never got to go out you
know seven years ago the Ace of Cups was
asked to perform at a birthday
celebration for summer of love
personality wavy gravy a young record
producer was in the audience and he
decided it was time to correct an
oversight I'm so long ago the Ace of
Cups first recorded album on HIGH moon
records has just been released with some
of the old songs and many new ones
reflecting the lives they've lived but
now of course we've been through a lot
motherhood and all raising teenagers so
the songs are a little bit more biting
but there's a lot of new songs it's like
I'm not gonna sing about why'd you leave
me babe I'm over here in a bar waiting
by myself because I'm not doing that and
those days are over I don't want to do
that
when you listen to that now when you
look at this film of you perform you are
you amazed at what you did at such a
tender age it was just life
it was just what we were doing you were
gonna tell me what your family thinks of
oh they're both just thrilled beyond you
were famous yeah I mean I mean I didn't
talk a lot to them about what happened
back then I think a lot of kids don't
know what their mothers were doing you
know thank heavens the Ace of Cups is
planning a tour next year they'll be
performing old songs from a new
perspective but it's funny when you're
at this age in your career like say if
we were in our 20s I always think it's a
blessing that we didn't get a recording
contract I don't think I'd be here now I
would do anything then you know there
was maybe destructive or whatever you
know now now that I'm 75 it's like I can
see how things are
[Music]
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone San Francisco
well I'm glad they're still here and we
finally got an Ace of Cups record and
they asked us strong vocals yes yeah and
can we can we just say how great it is
to see John Blackstone who's actually
retired but left us with that piece we
miss him already
we do Chris wacker definitely does his
produce producer yeah